you know there's been some interesting
stuff going on that are similar to what
you're talking about so
um
you know Jill Rogan who's do I have to
explain who Joe Rogan is no totally okay
so Joe
he you know had these had these um
doctors on to talk about covid and these
These are doctors that have a
non-mainstream media view about covid
and he just released a statement
yesterday because now we have some of
these old rock and roll people telling
Spotify if they don't pull Joe Rogan off
then we don't want our music off and and
that's a legitimate thing
um
so it's like okay so Rogan came out he
released like a Nine Minute Podcast last
night uh I happened to be driving and
when it came out started listening to it
and so this is what's interesting
uh I forget the examples that he gave
but one of them was six months ago or a
year ago or whatever
if you said cloth masks don't do
anything you would be literally banned
and there's documented people that were
banned from social media for saying that
and now it's oh it turns out it's
actually true and and for example CNN
has been widely reporting that there's a
whole list of things like that oh here's
here's the another example is
if you were to say six months ago or a
year ago
once you're vaccinated you can't catch
covet and you can't spread covid
and if you would have said that there's
people that were banned from social
media for saying those things and now
you look up and those things are
actually true they're factually true
that's what's happening
and you get this um
with the with the election results that
you're talking about in 2020.
there's
when people said hey I'm not sure about
this election right so some people
weren't necessarily saying I mean there
was politicians there was a very few
politicians that were saying hey
not so sure about this maybe we should
hold off maybe we should check the
results there was
personality social media personalities
that were saying that and they they got
shut completely shut down right not for
saying hey I think we should overthrow
the government but for saying hey
don't you think we should confirm this
because I I agree with you that to me
the worst outcome
for a for an American election is people
look at it and go I don't believe it
right even if it's a even if it's
never mind half the popular I don't want
ten percent of the population to think
hey I don't believe this is true I think
that that I think that the the election
results were wrong I think there was
Foul Play all those things
what I want to do is if 10 of the people
say or one percent of the people say hey
we think that there was foul play in the
elections
I want to say
okay well let's let's get everything out
on the table you know a good analogy
would be if you're watching if you're
playing a football game yeah and you
know a team
we think a team got a touchdown
and and the other team says yeah that
wasn't a touchdown
you don't say well shut up it was
because now we all leave and we don't
really think they they wanted we argue
about it we fight about it and it's a
bad thing instead what do we do what do
we do nowadays when there's that problem
we solve the problem by going oh
you don't think it was a touchdown cool
we're gonna go to the videotape right
we're gonna lay everything out on the
table and then everyone can see oh yeah
cross the plane it was a touchdown or
didn't cross the plane that's it we can
solve the argument so that we actually
get the truth out there
and and it seems like with this election
instead of saying
hey here's what happened in these
situations here's these anomalies that
took place here's why they took place
here's the impact that they have
actually had here's some characters that
did some things that they shouldn't have
done
here's some things that some accusations
were made that were totally false right
but but to just say
oh if you don't think that that election
was perfect right then you you you
should be silenced and and the reason I
bring up the the the the the masks and
the vaccines is because
right now it seems like there are some
people that are gathering evidence about
the election that might not necessarily
turn the election over but they might at
least say hey this is something that
happened this no one no one agrees that
this should happen no one agrees that
someone should be stuffing ballot boxes
right no no don't think you should be
stuffing ballot boxes right so if ballot
boxes are getting stuffed what can we do
to prevent that
and to me
I I can't imagine a a an American that's
aligned with America like with just the
the broad idea of America where we have
freedom of speech we have the right to
bear them the the bro we have the right
true life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness I can't imagine someone saying
ah you know what I actually think
stuffing Ballot Box is okay I actually
think think these these changing these
election laws is I think that's fine as
long as you know it's done for the right
party I that that to me doesn't make
sense right so I think when you start
talking about the thing that kind of
pushed you over the edge
I think there's a lot of people that
felt that way